[Music]
welcome back to good day las vegas it is
wednesday and it is time to talk to
metro sheriff joe lombardo once again
for our morning cup of joe's segment
sheriff good to see you once again
boring john all right cup of joe gotta
have it always
uh let's talk about an issue that was uh
right essentially before the pandemic
really set in here to southern nevada
the city of las vegas is a couple of
homelessness ordinances
uh what is going on with that it seemed
like the pandemic kind of had an effect
on
how that was enforced what citations
what kind of engagement has metro been
involved in when it comes to
trying to clean up parts of downtown
so the the intent of the ordinance was
to address the business
community and the residential community
to prevent people from
setting up camp per se within the
sidewalk areas obstructing business
practices
the majority of that population is
service adverse in other words they
don't want help
they chose unfortunately they sometimes
they choose that lifestyle
or or substance abuse or mental health
is causing them to have that lifestyle
and they don't may not even understand
the service availability
so we we offer that to them if they
accept services they move on
to that service we provide that service
to them if they say no
take me to jail in lieu of jail we issue
a citation
but happily to say the ordinance seems
to be working because
uh very few if any citations that i'm
aware of have been issued
and we've had the majority of
individuals accept services
okay sheriff it's been a little while
since uh the summer when we saw the
black lives matter protests across las
vegas we've talked about this before the
issue that you've discussed about
uh whether it's reform or adjustments
that can be made on a legislative level
to metro police to uh in dealing with
various parts of the community where do
things stand right now we have the
legislative session coming up early next
year
uh any movement in that regard any
conversations some of these require
some of these issues require extensive
conversation
and that you can't make in a couple days
um you have to talk about
both sides of the fence and you have to
talk about the unintended consequences
so some of those are you know the duty
to intervene uh
de-escalation their duty to render aid
the ability for um to
limit the choke hold or completely
outlaw it or or forbid it
uh depending on what legislative or what
state
decision making process is now when you
come into the regular session here
in february i'm sure the conversation
is going to continue when we talk about
reform and
and patterns and practice and ability to
audit what the
police officer does on a daily basis and
the mandate of body worn cameras
and all those so those discussions are
ongoing i am having those with the
attorney general and
and certain legislators um so
it's yet to be seen what they're gonna
want to push forward
and have discussions about well sheriff
we're just about out of time we do uh
thank you very much for joining us here
on good day las vegas once again
if you at home have a question for
sheriff lombardo you can submit it at
eightnewsnow.com just go ahead and find
out if your question is answered every
wednesday